he's here with us LOL a CO and welcome
to the D show we're here at the mass
picnic invention now have you ever had
some doubts creep into your mind and you
can't get them out maybe you've taken a
philosophy class 101 you're at the
University and now the professor has
planted a seed and now it's growing you
got some doubts about your Dean my next
guest is here to help you because that's
what he does he goes out and he talks to
people talks to the adults to you've to
help dispel those doubts to help you get
back inshallah God willing to be having
firmness on your Dean with my next guest
here on the D show we come back don't go
anywhere
this is the
this is the thing you know this is the
days of the teachers continue this is
the lecture I late mr. damn how are you
brother Valera shattering doubts yes
that's what you like to do I love it
it's my passion explained this when we
say shattering doubts what are you
trying to what are we trying to achieve
here well you know sometimes when we
talk about Amen about our faith and
belief we act like we're building in a
vacuum like it's just us and if we learn
it it's going to stay there but in
reality a prophet salla the Prophet
Muhammad's love the Haleiwa said them
says that he teaches us that Amen goes
up and down he says it wears out like
clothes wear from use and so shattering
the doubts is about recognizing that
we're all part of the fabric of the
society multicultural society multi
religious and we're being bombarded with
ideas from everywhere that we we love
that and there's a lot of good we live
in that but that also is a challenge to
our faith identity it's about embracing
the fact that we're going to have
questions we're going to have struggles
and we should be ready with the
approaches on how to deal with that so
we can keep our faith on the identity in
time how do you deal with this you know
the Muslim goes out or just the average
human being and he sees she sees a bus
ad and says I don't know if you've seen
this as there's probably no God so stop
worrying about and have a good time have
you seen these besides yeah and now
surrounds now you know we're creatures
of imitation now you got five in the
bunch you know and you're the only
Muslim and now the other four people are
like hey maybe that's right let's go to
the bar and have a drink yeah well how
do you deal with this panel oh you know
sometimes we do we react with that our
natural reaction can be one of fear
right that this I'm worried because
that's going to tear apart my faith and
I don't like to look at it like that I
like to recognize the opportunity that
you know what allah subhana allah says
in the quran well Idina Ted o ZM Holden
will attempt to quell those that that
work and struggle and go out and and try
to find faith try to be solved Muslims
Allah increases them in faith
so for me living with these challenges
is an opportunity to embrace the fact
that you know what I'm not perfect and I
was never meant to be when I hit with
these ideas that's that's a new
opportunity to revisit what am I about
what does it really mean to be Muslim
and what's the foundations of my faith
because you know let me tell you brother
Eddie the person that struggles and
sweats and asks and works hard there's a
way to do that so you got to do that in
a way that doesn't tear yourself apart
but if you know how to do that at the
end of that struggle you will taste a
sweetness of faith that somebody that
didn't struggle could never touch
because Allah is just if you're working
for it a la sao paulo tata wouldn't give
something to someone else on a silver
platter that you worked really hard to
find and i think that's that's the
Forgotten legacy of our companions how
about when you go into the land of
created out into some of the
university's right where there is
everything is about you know questioning
now that and God is excluded from
everything and it's really like the
professor's philosophy just you know
debate everything argue everything and
now you get into one of these classrooms
and a doubt is building up right what do
you are what advice do you have for the
University students that are going
through this you know a lot of people
want to have the freedom to question and
ask an explorer and I think to be fair
that's a short coming on our part as a
Muslim community we've made it taboo to
question and so I tell people when you
have questions we need to reimburse our
legacy that it's okay to have a doubt to
have a question as long as you pursue
that the right way you know no one would
take a kid and throw them into the ocean
if they don't know how to swim and
similarly we shouldn't throw ourselves
into the oceans of philosophy and debate
and so if we don't know what do we built
on and how do we navigate this and how
do I question in a way that doesn't tear
my faith apart but to look down on
questioning itself to look down on that
as if a question itself is going to tear
apart my fight I see no backing for that
in the religion in fact the prophecy is
Elam he was approached by two men that
had some awful doubt I say awful because
you know in the narration the narrow
didn't tell us what their question was
they said o Messenger of Allah we find
in our hearts that which is too awful to
mention imagine that guts to have a
question about religion and go to the
Messenger of God and say something's not
right like we don't understand something
the process and I send them you know if
unfortunately if we stereotype like
would think a lot of religious people
they would beat up on those brothers
right cross I sent him that wasn't his
reaction he said what God was yet to
Moses do you really finally said yes he
said van dyck oh sorry from email this
is true thing I wonder about that hadith
and I think part of what the process and
I'm praised was that when they had a
question they didn't post it to 500
Facebook friends none of whom were
specialized in that area none of them
have studied the DN and help them out
they went to somebody that could empower
them but i think he also praised them
for that struggle the courage to look in
the mirror and understand you know i
have shortcomings and challenges and i
can face myself and ask those questions
masha'Allah you guys having fun yet
we're going to be right back with more
here on the D show don't go anywhere
you
please subscribe to the diva follow us
on our official Facebook and Twitter
pages in the links below please also
help support the V show by making a
donation in the link below back here on
the Dean show with Mohammed and your
last name is a boot on some people are
like okay you know Eddie look you you
didn't even tell us who this guy is you
say some great stuff tell us a little
about yourself sure you know I tell
people I was born the Muslim parents but
I consider myself a convert you know I'm
dilemma my family we prayed we fasted
but we didn't really know what the Dean
was about and when I was a teenager I
started to get really interested in
learning more about religion seeing what
ppl makes people taken i started to read
the quran and other sacred scriptures of
other religions and eventually start to
memorize the 0 to n and I loved you know
religious studies but especially
studying us then and the Quran on the
other hand I love science i remember in
third grade did an experiment and i was
just hooked I love the scientific method
my whole life people were making me feel
like I was going to be torn into pieces
I remember you know one person said the
only way I keep my religion and my
science straits keep religion on one
half and science on the other I remember
going the messaging and feeling out of
place like people didn't appreciate my
love for academics then I turn around
and go to school and I remember one
teacher he said Muhammad come back here
when you're 18 you're too smart to
believe in God so for him religion with
just a temporary that's the professor
now that's what he said you're too smart
to believe it only too smart to believe
in God he figured when I grow up get
older come back I'll be an atheist so
you know for a long time I was trying to
find myself and I think we have to
embrace that you know scholars say the
worst deception is a deception of the
same to think you're something special
you're not we're all just we're
struggling trying to find
away but hamdullah over time you know I
eventually went to MIT that my doctorate
in engineering continued to memorize the
Quran and study a stem and I I love
being at that line in between loving my
aslam but loving also my profession I
work professionally as an engineer and
seeing the beauty of each in the other
tell us now Mohammed look when you have
a firm grounding in the basic
fundamentals of Islam right you know the
towhee the pure monotheism right you
have a sound belief system it's it's
it's you know it's grounded now and you
know what you're saying in the prayer
you know like many children they grow up
let's say their parents that teach them
how to pray they say Allah hug buddy
asking does that mean God is they don't
know they don't know that means it means
a lot the crater is the greatest right
then they put their heads down on the
ground they've been doing it for 10 15
years save some time that'll be at a
glory be to my lord the most high you
ask a look when I say it I get excited
but now maybe the the kid university
student he's been praying he don't even
know what that means there let her know
what tow he'd means let her know the
attributes of Allah now are you setting
yourself up for failure when that
professor tells you there's no God
you're not even really you're praying
just do the mechanics but the heart it's
really not connected how important is
this you know I can't emphasize enough
variety what you just said that's really
and you know as Muslims we have to bring
the issue back to a loss of panel data
like it's become commonplace so when
somebody gets religious the first thing
is they're drowning in branch matters of
felt and differences among the scholars
and we forget was that the companion how
the Companions built their amend did
they start studying all the differences
and fights an issue they started with a
loss apparel tada you know I'm one of
the people that I'm dying to me the full
of losses to go to in Jenna I really
want to meet Abu buck and with all
respect to abu bakr al dia lo han one of
the things I love about his story is you
know when he accepted Islam I can say
with confidence he knew less about Islam
and anybody watching this program I'm
not disrespecting him but even much of
the cold n hadn't been revealed but the
process of them says about him you know
his ax men
is like the whole amides it's heavier
and he says a buck didn't you know
proceed you get better than you buy just
lots of praying and worship but it was
something that settled in his heart so
we have to go back to the basics you
know understand what we're saying
incorrect understand who is alone what
are his attributes how did he describe
himself what does he want from me you
know and we cook when we come back to
those basics we become grounded there's
a big difference when when you're a men
when your faith is built on glass so
every question that passes by can
shatter the whole thing I'm fragile so
the next billboard the next horrible
thing that happens on the news I'm
finding my prayers affected I'm finding
my relationship or a lot affected when
you have that grounding it's not that
you don't question it's not that you
don't get challenged we all get
challenged but when we challenge we
don't get we don't take a nosedive
because we've got we've got that
grounding you know when we don't have it
it's like we're looking at the world
through a pinhole and when we do have it
the whole world falls into place because
it starts and it ends and it's all
guided by Allah Subhan O God amazing
we're going to take another break very
exciting episode of the Dean show
because this is something prevalent now
absolutely Shaitaan is working to create
those doubts and if we set ourselves up
for failure by not being equipped with
the knowledge and a connection to our
Creator where we're bound to fail so
we're going to be helping you guys to be
firm and Charlotte with some great
advice when we come back here a TV show
don't worry one please subscribe to the
dvo follow us on our official Facebook
and Twitter pages in the links below
please also help support the V show by
making a donation in the link below back
here on the D show and we're shattering
the doubts now you see a individual now
let's contrast is back to what I was
saying about not being grounded in the
fundamentals the basics of Islam and you
have let's say this testimonial of a
Christian he was like a Muslim Imam or
whatever and you'd like you start to be
doubtful you but how could someone leave
Islam you know what
me and then you're like you know
listening to their story and okay and
you're listening or you're talking to
someone and usually the litmus test you
I asked the person I say okay can you
tell me you know that Fatiha you were
supposed to be reciting it if you were
praying can you define it for me what
does it mean and the person a he can't
recite them fatty huh and B he doesn't
know the meaning right so right there
you'll see that either this is just you
know someone making up a story or that
person never knew Islam in the first
place because you begin look with the
opening chapter of the Quran for the
prayer you don't know what it means you
follow me and that goes back to what I'm
saying what we're just talking about
really knowing what you're saying
knowing why you believe in what you
believe and questioning right with the
with the anticipation to get to know the
answers humbly question not arrogantly
rightfully so have you seen some of
these people that are out there saying
that they you know they've you watch
some of these videos or some people or
you may be met someone who now they say
they were Muslim and then they left
Islam but then had really no none of the
fundamentals no no no ground in the
fundamentals yeah it's such a challenge
today right now because all you have to
do is turn up turn on the news right
yeah and Islam and Muslims are going to
be painted it in a way that makes them
look backwards and awful I tell you if
they were the way that they're
stereotyped to me none of us would want
to be within 100 years the one right so
it's a challenge because you know we're
constantly bombarded with these images
with these pictures that make Islam and
Muslims look backward but I made a
decision when I was younger I made a
decision that that my heart my mind my
life are too valuable for me to do the
wrong thing because somebody out there
even if they look religious even if they
if they have that long beard or this
look or whatever that they're going to
define a stand for I knew that I want to
meet a lost power to Isla you know
having made
principled decision myself and I think
one of the big problems we have you know
with these things is that we sit around
the coffee table and we feel powerless
because that that video is out there
affecting people and or that horrible
thing happened thousands of miles away
and look it hurts our hearts and it's a
big issue but I'd encourage you know our
viewers and myself and yourself to do is
don't feel powerless go out and and know
that Allah is going to ask you about
yourself and those you touch counter
that narrative in the small ways that
you can like put a good example for
yourself for your family for your
neighbors and leave the rest of us
cantata but if I can't guard my heart of
mind if I can't make decisions about
that fundamentals based on what's right
and wrong but just what other people are
doing then I'm just going to be with
whatever click whatever is going on in a
moment that's not how we should live
tools what tool is now you know when you
go on to a battle right you have the
proper tools you want to defend yourself
you take a martial art you got the tools
equipped to go ahead and defend yourself
and any life-threatening situation
nowadays you know everything is trying
to suck the Iman out of you right
straight down there's this you know
invitation to everything that's immoral
promiscuous you know so many bad things
out there how do you put what what
advice do you give for people to equip
themselves with the tools to be able to
fight off all of this these negativities
and the temptations etc you know i'll
share with you the number one tool that
I've experienced firsthand has helped a
lot of people I remember meeting a
wonderful young brother but he was who
was struggling with a lot of questions
and I remember as we were chatting it
was such a challenge to even answer them
because we would get partway through one
question and his mind would pull in
another one and then I saw this but and
then this happened and that happened
over see this was really overwhelming
the brother and so the tool we brought
into that situation is a tool that I
call the parking lot
what he did it's open your favorite
program your notes program on your phone
Google Doc even a sheet of paper and
embrace that it's okay that I don't
understand everything I have the courage
to face myself just just Park what's
bothering you what's on your mind almost
like a dart just put them all down and I
remember that that brother he had been
spending eight years on some of these
questions he asked the Big E mam's the
YouTube personalities eight years there
were no questions that came off that
list only more that came on at home
denied by the mercy of Allah alone after
he put down that parking lot he parked
46 questions on that list but what
change the questions didn't change but
something Hum Dil that changed in his
heart and mind he went from being led
around by his questions to him being in
control all right how am I going to
build my a man how am I going to go
about this and he had just one rule he
said I only deal with one question at a
time that's what I told him brother that
most important one put it at the top
everything else it'll be waiting for you
when you come back well I brother Eddie
you know incredibly humbling experience
in two weeks he had knocked off a third
of his questions and he hadn't been able
to do that for eight years before so I'd
really share with myself with all of us
you know use that parking lot but when
then you go after that question you have
to go after it with with with sound
scholars with people that that talk the
talk and walk the walk people that
really you know show is them and it's
true colors that can help you navigate
those waters as you build and develop
your email how important what you say is
it is the sincerity and the question
because you can be asking questions and
the creator knows what's in your heart
if you're not playing games or you
sincerely want to know and now you're
humbly coming to ask with the intention
that now you
want to learn more about your crater
you're not just looking for a loophole
in the law to go ahead and maybe have
this you know via means for you to go
ahead and go out and follow your desires
so now you find something that doesn't
fit with you right you're not sincere
and then you know a lot let you go to
where you got going to go because now
the intention was right so how important
is is you know without sincerity we can
ask but that asking is not going to take
us a good place we believe as Muslims
that that sincerity is so important you
know I'm reminded of a verse in the
Quran and it talks about you know that
some things are clear and other things
have differences upon but it's a lost
speaking right so he says something
incredible because Allah knows our
intentions right we just judge actions
but Allah speaks about what's in the
heart he says hi melody nephew
Colombians ate those that literally it
means in their hearts they know they
should go this one but they want to go
around that's the linguistic meaning
it's like our lack of sincerity it says
pet abrir una meta shibaemon hoped LOL
fit now up to heart that will it says
they go after issues of difference
confusing things issues with his moto
opinions but he says why looking for
fitna looking for problems and looking
for far-fetched interpretations that's
what I'm talking about so Allah tells
you you want you can fool me you can
fool the [ __ ] but you can't fool a lost
power God and he says well may I limit
that we l'ho in the law none that know
its true meaning except Allah but then I
love continues about what we should do
that we should you know seek with
sincerity and by the way we don't
question for fun in this then we
question to change ourselves understand
that when we question we take a
responsibility on ourselves that when i
get that answer when i get closer I'm
not questioning for fun I'm questioning
because I want to be a better person
because I know at the end of the day I'm
going to answer for what I did with
so in Islam is not we got a few minutes
left so it's right that Islam you know
there's no problem with asking questions
sincerely it's not just about blindly
you know people really love islam
because there's evidence there's proof
to back up why we believe that this
crown is from the crater why the problem
ahamed is indeed a messenger from God so
we don't shy away from from these
questions right absolutely not you know
i love the verse in the quran found
amanda has lately hello the the
foundation and then our law says found
him go work to know that this is true
you see II Men for us it's not a magic
trick it takes investment it takes hard
work and then a lots of Carl to I
blesses you but you gotta start you
gotta want it and so absolutely it's
okay to question but question with them
within you know with a system knowing
that ultimately this is taking upon and
one you know quick piece of advice that
I would just share is that I think one
of the worst things for our amen today
is is a website crazy fellow calm look
it's not a real website but it's a
phenomenon right that people are
discrediting the Dean because you know
we post questions and then anybody post
anything on the Internet to discredit it
like you know this is just a hodgepodge
s is nothing so when when we question we
really look to those of understanding of
education enough character of character
because that sincerity is so important
questions don't go away by wishful
thinking they don't go away by magic
they go away by learning by discipline
by intention and by hard work thank you
very much is a pleasure baking that most
pleasure having you photos up with you
with our only confuses on it and thank
you for tuning in to the D show and I
hope you got to benefit sincerity the
right intention and sincerely asking the
one who created you to guide you and
anytime that you have some doubts a
right there stop and drop the Muslim you
know that now you have this direct dial
up connection with the one who made you
that's right and then obviously ask
those questions sincerely in sha allah
god women law will facilitate away but
those adults can be erased subscribe if
you haven't already tune in every week
to the dean show until then please do
with you something please subscribe to
the dvo follow us on our official
facebook and twitter pages in the links
below please also help support the V
show by making a donation in the link
below